[Music]
[Applause]
he's Nick Wright first things first
co-host on Fox Sports 1 and he uh joins
us on the program where do you want to
start
well you listen let's deal with the
elephant in the room you're very very
mad at me when I think once you get the
full context you'll be very very proud
of me okay I think you will say this is
why I have taken young Nick Wright under
my wing okay because this is the type of
broadcaster and friend he is but would
you like to set it up would you like to
get the context okay so I won the
Marconi award which is the biggest award
you can win it's for the national radio
host and Nick was at the ceremony was
going to go up and accept it and uh you
know there was a connection there
because we put in a clip from an
interview that we did with Nick so he
was part of the tape that we submitted
and I thought you know what let me thank
him I got a miniature Marconi and I sent
it to him surprised him to say thank you
next thing I know I get an email or
fritzy does he goes uh Nick gave away
your Marconi it was on a radio interview
in Boston and he gave it away and then I
text Nick and I said I gave it to you as
a gift a thank you you gave it away as a
joke I hope you gave away the watch that
I gave you as well
okay well first of all I'd never give
the watch away sell it
but never give it away okay but you have
a few of the so I was at the marconis
with Danny Parkins who hosts afternoons
on the score in Chicago okay that's
important context okay I wasn't on a
radio interview in Boston I was on
Danny's radio station in Chicago when
this came up so now this is where I
think so he was nominated he didn't win
because Greg Hill from Boston won I
don't know what they submitted that's
outrageous but doesn't matter okay so
this is where I think you will say you
know what Nick you it was good move okay
so Danny
about a month ago I don't know if you'll
like me saying this but you know what
we're all friends here was dealing was
in some contract negotiations and you
know how those radio negotiations can at
times get contentious and he never
wanted to leave Chicago who's never
planning on leaving Chicago but I told
him hey we gotta you know you need as
much leverage as possible so some Big
Boys come out try to hire you maybe even
get the dollars up or something
so we made so I was like you'll probably
have like a zoom interview at some point
with someone you already have on the
resume
nominated for a Marconi but you can't
put on it you want it but what if in the
background there is the there is a
Marconi statue and they're like oh he
just didn't update the resume he won a
Marconi they're not gonna google it I
was like so you just have that there
until this contract stuff gets taken
care of and then send it back to me so
that's what he's doing and you know you
can hear him on the score in Chicago you
hear him on First and pot a great
podcast he does with Andrew filippone
he's a great radio host who now his he's
got two small children just bought a
house in Chicago she's got a great new
contract so your that is what we call
paying it forward you did something nice
for me I did something nice for him now
it comes back to me Raleigh shows up on
eBay in a few months but you didn't
convey that as a radio host as a
journalist you didn't convey the story
accurately to fritzy
therefore fritzy conveyed it to me well
so listen I didn't convey anything to
fritzy I sent fritzy a link now if
you're saying that the folks who are
currently on the sports media beat that
maybe they need to dust up on some
journalism glasses that's you know
that's for you to say all I did was send
fritzy a link to a story that had been
written I said show this to Dan I didn't
vouch for it I didn't do any of those
things and let me tell the audience
something else Dan sends texts with odd
punctuation and weird emojis and I can
never tell is this because he's old and
Confused or is he sad and I got this
text the other morning and I'm like I
think I hurt my friend's feelings and so
I was really anxious about this well
um I did send when he goes are you mad
or are are you jealous why are you upset
at me my my insides are turning upside
down I was worried and then I go even
the clown has tears Nick that's what he
wrote
I could see you today and I go I got him
and he goes what got me and I told him I
said oh yeah he's all he's a mess now
because I didn't respond
[Laughter]
let me give one more piece of context
then we can talk football and basketball
and everything okay this all you had six
hours prior asked if I wanted to go to
dinner yes and and you know what I'll
tell you this because you'll like it but
I I'm going to dinner with uh coach Eric
Mangini and his wife tonight so I
couldn't uh my wife's coming with us a
little double date I said to my wife I
was like ah Dan invited me to dinner but
I can't because we have manginis do you
know what my wife said my wife who we
don't have to go down that road again
she said I'll go with him oh I said you
gotta be kidding me
I'ma break that Marconi in halfway dude
I am playing the long game with your
wife
I'm just letting you know jono yeah she
loves love just like I do
okay all right uh he's Nick Wright he's
our good buddy from Fox Sports One we're
all good we're all good okay thank you
yeah we are we are are good but man I
wanted I wanted you to grind over this
big time I was okay why is Mahomes being
disrespected in your mind
well it's just I just
and people
evidently want to treat the best
quarterback in the world title like it's
the heavyweight championship Crown like
if you lose to a guy he just gets it and
I had to listen all year long about how
it's Mahomes Allen Allen Mahomes who
knows this guy might be better and it
was nonsense total complete nonsense and
I was called a hater for saying Josh
Allen isn't even the second best
quarterback in the world Joe burrow is
and everyone thought the bills were
going to roll the Bengals except for me
when I correctly predicted the bill
season for the third year in a row and
then the moment the bills lose now it's
oh I'm a homesboro Mahomes who knows I
guess we'll see if they it's so that's
the first reason it's nonsense second
reason nonsense this Dan I want to give
America a very quick lesson of what
Patrick Mahomes in the playoffs has
meant his first year in the playoffs 24
fourth quarter points and three fourth
quarter comebacks against Bill
Belichick's defense including a drive
with in less than 30 seconds of course
overtime they don't get the coin flip
they lose they didn't like Buffalo go
cry into the commissioner change the
rules change the rules took their
medicine the next year three
double-digit comebacks including 21
points in less than six minutes of the
fourth quarter of the Super Bowl against
the League's best defense then next year
back in the Super Bowl and has the Tampa
Bay Bucs I tweeted out the video of it
in awe on the sideline as he's throwing
passes horizontal to the ground bouncing
off guy's face masks the next year in
the playoffs was last year they scored
42 42 21 in the first half and then
Mahomes had his version of LeBron's 2011
finals short-circuited for a half a
football lost in the game and in this
year he has a damn flu game except it's
a sprained an ankle game people like I
don't know Joe burrow beats him he's a
better player give me a break
give me a break and my home's gonna go
put on a show this weekend well you also
have to factor in that Mahomes has had
one good quarter in eight quarters in
the Super Bowl that's okay but it's not
true it's flatly not true watch the
Bucks game again Dan he was brilliant he
was brilliant and passes are being
dropped watch it doesn't no we don't do
that you don't go oh you know what the
the receivers do you do this for any
other quarterback when you go back in
time you go boy man they lost they
dropped all of those passes or he would
have uh you know won that game you're
doing it from homes
I mean you're blurring the lines here
that's his team they dropped the ball
what happens you know you're you're
trying to make it seem like he had two
touchdowns four picks
I'm not in two Super Bowls I'm not
blurring any lines his quarterback
rating is 64 in the Super Bowl he's not
been great now you can say his teammates
didn't help him well we can say that
about a lot of quarterbacks in the Super
Bowl what's your favorite Tom Brady what
do you think is the most impressive Tom
Brady Super Bowl Dan
what's the best one there's only one
there's so many
no The 28-3 Comeback is the answer
that's what everyone would go to he
threw a pick six in that game to get
down 28-3 and then led the comeback the
idea that we're gonna act like coming
back from down double digits with six
minutes left against the League's best
defense and then winning by the double
digits is not a wildly impressive Super
Bowl performance against the Niners is
nonsense now you want to say he
underachieved against the Bucks I think
the film disagrees but despite that
passer rating that you mentioned in the
Super Bowl the guys played in 12 playoff
games has the all-time best passer
rating in the postseason the all-time
best touchdown interception ratio in the
postseason the all-time best yards per
game in the postseason so what I'm here
is telling you is he is an all-time
legendary postseason performer and now
people are doubting what he's going to
look like on Sunday he's in his own
category I asked the question earlier
this week quarterback you want to start
your team with we took Mahomes out of
the conversation he's in his own
conversation yes but I'm just saying
he's not everything that you're saying
he is
he's not in the Super Bowl he's not and
and we are welcoming somebody to come in
to the conversation that's what this
what that's what burrow is about he's
can we have somebody in the conversation
because nobody is in the conversation
Josh Allen's not Justin Herbert's not
Jalen hurt says and is Joe burrow at
least going to make this a fun
conversation and I'm fine with that I'll
be very quick here okay I have all year
said Joe Burrows the second best
quarterback in football what frustrates
me is the lack of consistency from my
media colleagues who all year long said
Alan and Mahomes were neck and neck and
were putting burro down with Herbert
down in a different tier and then what
is your name names call out who did this
literally everyone but me literally
everyone in the media but Nick Wright
that's the names okay
um we're on the same page with uh Lebron
with what LeBron is doing I I just I'm
I'm amazed that this isn't bigger I know
that it's going for Kareem's record but
nobody has had this nobody's had a
season like this and LeBron is doing
this on a nightly basis and he has to
because Anthony Davis isn't there
I don't know that just I'm trying to
figure this out you know why I tell you
it's the protection of Michael Jordan
I mean that's all it is it's it's you
can't this was a record Dan
in the last 55 years
here are the people who have held the
title of NBA's all-time leading scorer
I'll give you the full list it'll take a
while Wilt Chamberlain Kareem
Abdul-Jabbar yeah that's the list yeah
Kareem set this record or broke the
record before LeBron was born
it was considered unbreakable up to six
years ago people thought it couldn't be
broken
LeBron's gonna break it by 4 000 points
five thousand points six thousand points
and the reason I say it's the protection
of Jordan
is when the timeline goes long enough
folks are gonna be like okay so tell me
the argument explain to me why Jordan's
the greatest they'll be like oh winner
it's like oh he had the most
championships no uh Kareem had the same
oh but it's tied for the most no
actually this guy named Bill Russell who
had 11. okay well that can't be it then
uh he played like he did it the longest
no it's not even not even close actually
oh I know what it is he's the greatest
scorer ever well kind of but he's
actually fifth on the all-time list and
10 000 points behind the all-time score
right now this moment Dan there is a
bigger Gap in points between LeBron and
Jordan than Jordan and Paul Pierce by
the end of the season the gap between
LeBron and Jordan will be the same as
the gap between Jordan and your guy
Reggie Miller so it's like so then the
argument just has to be well oh oh I get
it was he playing during the toughest
year of basketball was he just going
through super team after super team it's
like well
no in the East he had to go through a
Knicks team that had one Hall of Famer
to go to the finals against a Blazers
team that had won Hall of Famer and then
the sons that had one Hall of Famer and
then the sonics that had one Hall of so
it's like then wait why is he the
universally accepted goat
it's like oh I don't know man but people
have always said it so I guess you had
to be there and so that LeBron's going
to be scoring 30 a night when he breaks
This Record that's unfathomable it's
totally unfathomable that he's still one
of the eight best players in the league
but you know people might look at uh
career average Jordan's what it's 30.
LeBron's at 27. if that factors in but
I'm I'm with you on all of this LeBron's
going to end up in the top five and
assist
when it's all so the greatest score is
not a great shooter and he's going to be
one of the top five passers in the
history of the game and it's not
compiling you know this is and I'm going
to average 21 a game and you know six
assists and five well that's the other
important part of it maybe at some point
he'll get there but the fact that he's
breaking the record when he's arguably
playing at a First Team all-nba level
even I I'll tell you this you know
LeBron's got that ad campaign you know
the LeBron versus father time yeah if
you watched the first 10 games of the
year
I was like oh boy I think Father Time
finally caught up like it looked like
LeBron had shifted from where he was
last year to like a a fringe top 25 guy
then he would miss two weeks came back
since he turned 38 Dan he's averaging 36
points per game like he has been since
after that was opening two weeks of the
Season he's been as good as anybody in
the league and so there's no context for
it I wonder if people look at Jordan and
LeBron the way we do Jim Brown versus
Emmett Smith
that the yards aren't close Jim Brown
was something we had never seen before
Emmett came along and dominated as far
as you know career rushing yards here's
what here's where I would say I I under
I think that's a really good calm to a
degree where I would disagree is if we
just went the Jim Brown if you put Jim
Brown and Emmitt Smith's careers
together and said pick out the five best
singular Seasons they'd all be Jim Brown
Seasons right you know what I mean if
you did that with Jordan and LeBron it'd
go back and forth back and forth It's
not like maybe you can say Jordan's Peak
if you want to argue it was a touch
higher I don't know the year LeBron had
a 27 game winning streak and almost one
Defensive Player of the Year and was one
vote away from unanimous MVP was pretty
good but you want to say Jordan's Pete
was a touch higher so be it but it's not
substantial and they're the best seasons
for each of those guys can go Tit for
Tat and ultimately people are going to
be like well who was the better you know
let's go age by age like who was the
better teenager well Jordan was
averaging 13 a game for Carolina and
LeBron was making all-star teams well I
guess that's LeBron who was the better
38 year old well Jordan was averaging 20
a game for a below 500 Wizards team
LeBron is in the you know first team all
NBA discussion so yeah if you we want to
say late 20s to 31 Jordan was better
it's close but fine but the body of work
is so overwhelming it's not going to
ultimately it's not going to be an
argument yeah people won't entertain
that and and I that's where I have a
problem with it what is wrong with
consistency durability the totality of
this why can't he be the greatest player
of all time just because you have your
memories and you're growing up with
Michael Jordan and we all fell in love
with everything
it it feels like you know we're we're
very begrudgingly acknowledging the
greatness of LeBron we're seeing the
great greatest player of all time in my
opinion right in front of us but we'll
we're not going to acknowledge it maybe
after the fact and it's almost
sorry you know also want to acknowledge
it his god dog GM who comes out and
gives a quote he's like I'm not going to
make a trade unless you know it makes us
a championship Contender it's like all
right buddy so LeBron's playing at a
better level than you could have hoped
Anthony Davis is now back he's playing
he was playing the best of his career uh
Ross is actually working in the role
he's in and the coach has been good so
all those things happened that your best
case scenario check check check
and you don't think the team's already a
contender well why because the roster's
terrible whose job is that polinka I
forget oh they got this so the guy who
built the team says the team's not good
enough to improve it's maddening it's
utterly Madness see Jordan is Neil
Armstrong that's the problem
he's second LeBron is second on the moon
oh that's you know what that's better
than the Jim Brown Emmitt Smith thing I
don't know which one of your guys fed
you that line but that's that's vintage
Dan Patrick yeah I mean that is it
really adds your fastball don't be here
that's great don't be hating don't be
happy
so but here's I guess what I'm doing
right now is spitting
okay okay now you're so on that note
here's the here's the question I would
ask people
who's the
why is Jay-Z the greatest rapper ever
because he is and it's because the body
of work is so overwhelming it's
impossible to deny now if you want to
argue Tupac's best album is better than
Jay-Z's so be it but he didn't do it
long enough and the thing with Jordan is
Jordan quit twice he could have it's not
like oh nobody played that long no
Kareem did Carl Malone did those guys
played that long Jordan
left five seasons on the table that was
his choice so be it but we can't then be
like well he would have won all these
other titles we don't know that what we
do know is as far as who has created the
most winning basketball it's one guy in
league history by a mile and it's also
why I think Kareem's the second best
player ever top three is not bad Jordan
if you include College in there
Kareem's well if you include College
Kareem's got the greatest basketball
life ever yes if you include College
he's the greatest basketball life ever I
like what your wife has done with uh the
house there
why do you think it's on me
you don't think I'm the one designing
this stuff you can't even cut your hair
I mean come on you got no shot you're
better no shot you're better than that
uh no shot let's have yeah thank you
let's have dinner soon are you going to
be I'll see you at the Super Bowl yeah
yeah but uh have fun with Eric Mangini
and his wife I'm sure it'll be riveting
conversation you know breaking down I
don't appreciate that tone I don't
appreciate that tone at all that's my
dear friend Dan don't you do that I'll
talk to you later tell your wife I said
hello I won't actually be doing that at
all I won't even tell her that I'm on
this show today see you later all right
buddy that's uh Nick Wright back after
this